There are several noteworthy features of this constraint.
The first is the use of the implies keyword to denote logical implication,
which is just a way of saying the restriction is only true for children.
It is equivalent to the use of the right right arrow in first order logic.
The second feature is the, the OCL use of the right arrow,
this one with only one horizontal line. And that's used with collection classes.
So in the case where there's a collection on the left hand side and you wish to,
access or make use of one of the built in operations in this case size,
you can use this right arrow
to say you'd like to bring in the size operation on this particular collection
class. The other types of collections that we'll get to but
all of them have a size operation associated with it